well not everyone will get to be home
for the holidays this year
but for walker furniture not even a
pandemic will stop the deliveries for
dozens of deserving families in need but
the program is being altered for
safety's sake
[Music]
we knew that it was important to give
back to the community in a significant
way
and what better way than giving
furniture
but filling a home with new sofas beds
and tables
brings much more to someone who
desperately needs their spirits lifted
this time of year
to receive furniture during the time of
christmas
offered so much hope not only did they
need the furniture
but it was something they felt like an
answered prayer larry alterweights ceo
of walker furniture
didn't realize home for the holidays
would become a household
name when the program started 27 years
ago
asking the community to write letters of
deserving las vegas
dear mr alterweights i'm writing on
behalf of a vietnam veteran
who has had to leave an abusive family
with just the shirt on his back
dear walker furniture my daughter has
stage four cancer and have had to quit
my job
we have nothing left oh there's just so
many
really heart-wrenching stories you
really can't take care of all the need
hundreds of letters pour out heartfelt
pleas for help
whittled down to a dozen homes of
furniture the first year
and today has generously grown to 35.
but the challenges of covid during
shutdowns earlier this year
brought worries of their own to the
walker furniture family you know what
are you going to do
you're closed down no one come in the
store you're concerned about your
employees you're concerned about your
community
and you're concerned about your business
thankfully the stores were closed less
than two months and business is good
safety is the primary concern for
customers and employees
i've told my organization that pandemic
or no pandemic
home for the holidays is happening but
there is some ba humbug this year
as most of the families ultimately
chosen will have to wait until after
christmas
when volunteers can safely visit and
verify the need of nominees
which is greater than ever in 2020.
hopefully
home for the holidays encourages others
other community leaders other businesses
and individuals to reach out and
do good for one another i think that's
what we need in this world today
we sure do need it now that's for sure
well the deadline to send in
or drop off a letter has been extended
to christmas day so if you know someone
get that nomination in a handful of
furniture deliveries will be made next
week
to families in dire need and they have
been identified by
metro police north las vegas police and
clark county fire department
helping hands a vegas valley they verify
all of the homes that become the final
recipients
and then there's an executive committee
which also helps with that
and that will happen next year as soon
as it's safe
coveted safe for everyone so you know
larry alterwitz just wants to make sure
that those volunteers are safe
and they can safely enter all those
homes that no one wants to get sick and
just want to be as healthy as possible
so it may happen in january may happen
in february
it will happen it's just changing a
little bit this year but nate you know
so many families are struggling these
days
across the valley and this program has
been around for such a long time does
such great work to help people that are
really in need
yeah i was thinking about this and
imagining that they're getting even
more referral letters this year than
they have in the past and uh
john and sherry you and i are along with
other folks in the media and here at the
tv station
uh i get to look at those letters and
boy they are just gut-wrenching i can't
imagine how tough they are this year
they really are can imagine they're
going to be more dire than ever
don't you think it's heartbreaking
especially this time of year you know
there's something about having a bed a
bed or a couch or some
aspect of furniture to have a family
around to to support yourself at home so
it's an important program as you said
sherry it'll happen it'll just uh take a
little longer this year unfortunately
sure will
yeah and larry wants to thank all the
partners too that help with the program
star nursery
delivers trees and the las vegas rescue
mission delivers gifts and
money cards so there's just a lot of
community partners that help